thousands of protesters have rallied in
sudan's capital khartoum calling for the
transitional government to be dissolved
and replaced by a military
administration
the protests follow a failed coup
attempt in september and come amid deep
divisions among the factions governing
the east african country sudan has been
ruled by an uneasy alliance of military
and civilian groups since the toppling
of autocratic president omar al-bashir
in 2019 but support for the government
has waned in recent months in the face
of tough economic reforms
well we're joined now by jonas horner
he's working for the international ngo
crisis group and is based in the
sudanese capital khartoum i welcome to
dw now why are these protesters taking
are these protests taking place now
well these protests take place in the
context of a um a coup attempt that
occurred about three weeks ago that
brought the existing tensions within
this uh hybrid military civilian
government out into the open uh and
brought things into a more overt uh
overt platform uh you know the the
military's concerns uh military have
concerns about uh the prospect of
justice or uh abuses that that were
committed during the bashir era and
since then during sudan's revolution
they're concerned about
the handover of the sovereign council
which is which is an executive body in
government um that they currently are
our chairs of uh and pressure on on for
them to give over military companies
you also have a split in the civilian
side of the transition government the
forces of freedom and change um and and
really i think you also are hitting an
existential moment for sudan with
parties who are part of the government
and wanting to be part of the government
seeking really to control what comes
next following elections that are
scheduled for 2024.
right now
you touched on it there um but sudanese
dictator omar al-bashir was ousted by
the army in in april 2019 tell us more
about the role of the military in sudan
over the past two years
certainly well you know as i said the
military are one uh part of the hybrid
transitional government that is uh
governing sudan's tradition uh in
advance of these elections scheduled for
2024. um
so much of the protesting against bashir
originally also you know included overt
uh calls for a move to a civilian
government and and of course by by by
extension a move away from civilians
from military dominance of sudan's
politics and and the economy and
certainly for the last 30 years of omar
bashir the military have dominated the
economy they they run the key sectors of
the economy and have always benefited
from from key key advantages there you
know in this transitional period they
they have unfortunately dragged their
feet and blocked key reforms
particularly on the economy
and other areas um and they've also sort
of offered this false dichotomy that
suggests that they're the only ones who
can
be the deliverers of security in sudan
when in fact you know what what the
protesters of the revolution sought was
for a a civilian command the control of
the military and for civilians to really
take charge of their own security rather
than having the military dominate
politically and in the security sector
jonas horner senior analyst for sudan
working for the international ngo crisis
group in khartoum thank you for uh for
talking to us today
thank you